[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment une tartine de fromage un jeune
sans diplôme est un des plus grands
auteurs américains peuvent vous préparer
à vivre une vie qui vous correspond
encore plus je m'appelle julie et ça
fait dix ans que j'étudie comment nos
perceptions influence notre manière de
vivre
je trouve que l'humain est fascinant par
sa capacité à se dépasser mais aussi
parfois s'autolimiter on a tous des
choses dans la vie qui nous inspire qui
nous donne de l'énergie
ça peut être passer du temps en famille
peuvent voyager faire du sport
développer son entreprise et j'en passe
dans mes recherches j'ai découvert une
série de questions qui me permet de
révéler ce qui inspire une personne et
si j'avais l'opportunité de dîner avec
chacun d'entre vous je vous demanderais
par exemple tiens si tu peux avoir une
pièce de plus dans son logement et que
cette pièce n'était rien qu'à toi
qu'est-ce qu'on y trouverait dedans ou
alors je vous demanderais si on
travaille en plein milieu de la nuit
pour te raconter quelque chose de super
enthousiasmant il faudrait que ce soit à
propos de quoi pour que tout de suite ça
donne de l'énergie tu veux en savoir
plus pourquoi je vous poserai ces
questions pour observer à quel moment
votre regard s'illumine votre volume
sonore ces temps-ci suis votre posture
se redresse et aussi découvrir ce qui
vous donne deux l'entousiasme tous ces
éléments m'indique de quoi serait fait
une vie qui vous correspond alors en
soit l'idée simple sur le papier pour
être heureux ville habitée de correspond
simplement parfois il va c'est pas si
facile parce que des obstacles se
présente sur notre chemin
j'avais 8 ans un dimanche c'est ma
grand-mère avec mes parents et comme
souvent elle a envie de me faire plaisir
alors elle me dit tiens je vais voir si
je peux te faire une petite tartine de
fromage fondu
elle ouvre son frigo et elle me dit
âgées du camembert
je réponde dommage bah pourquoi bas
parce que ça fonde pas si sa faune bannu
est sûre c'est mo s mais un rire mes
parents aussi le fromage alors la scène
a certes l'air banal mais quelque chose
de marquant se passe pour moi à ce
moment là un mois auparavant
mon père m'avait dit que le camembert sa
fondée pas définir mais tout simplement
cru alors ce jour là chez ma grand mère
je réalise qu'il ya des choses que je
crois vrai et qui ne sont pas forcément
je réalise que peu importe la raison ce
que les gens peuvent dire et parfois
faux je réalise que dans ma vie je vais
avoir intérêt à remettre en question ce
que je crois c'est drôle ses croyances
qu'on a sur nous sur la vie sur les
autres et qui sont pas forcément vrai
d'ailleurs pour la plupart on en a à
peine conscience ce qui est moins drôle
c'est quand ces croyances nous empêche
de réaliser ce qui est important pour
nous pour moi c'est pas faux listings
je suis pas la hauteur j'ai peur de
déranger
j'ai peur d'être jugé à mon âge on fait
pas ça c'est trop tard j'imagine que
vous avez déjà connu ce genre de pensée
j'ai croisé tellement de personnes qui
meurent dans vie de dire je t'aime à
leurs proches mais qui n'osent pas parce
que dans ma famille sasy pa
j'ai parlé déranger j'ai croisé
tellement de personnes qui n'osent pas
vivre la vie que les inspire parce
qu'ils ne remettent pas en question ce
genre de pensée et vous quelles
croyances vous auriez intérêt à remettre
en question pour vivre la vie qui vous
inspire il ya 11 ans j'ai découvert à
quel moment il est indispensable de
remettre en question ce qu'on croit ma
vie a pris un tournant sur la c'était le
soir dans le bus en rentrant chez moi
quand j'étais en deuxième année de fac
d'économie
je pense à un ami à qui la vie sur les
patrons en ce moment il s'appelle
anthony la lâcher
depuis longtemps donc il n'a pas diplôme
il est vendeur d'un magasin de bricolage
ça lui plaît pas tant que ça alors
qu'est ce que je ferais je sais je lâche
mon job et je pars à l'aventuré en
australie à leurs rêves
dommage que je ne puisse pas faire
pareil dommage que je puisse pas faire
pareil cette pensée m'a fait un
électrochoc
comment ça je peux pas le faire bah
parce que tu es des études et alors
matata licence après tu attends masters
après attirer intégrer une super
entreprises donc c'est pas qu'on patine
attend quelque chose qui cloche
moi on m'a toujours dit travail bien
fait des études tu seras libre de faire
ce que tu veux
pour ça que j'ai pris ce chemin ce pour
être libre tu es comme en maintenant bas
c'est vraiment des conseillers mais si
tu tiens faire tu pars entre ta licence
et en master et à ce moment là je
ressens une bouffée d'entousiasme parce
que je venais de me donner la permission
de vivre ce rêve
et qu'est-ce que j'ai bien fait ça a été
une des plus belles années de ma vie
j'en ai profité pour réaliser tous mes
rêves les plus simples comme sauter en
parachute sauter à l'élastique nager
avec des dauphins avec un requin baleine
et j'en passe
voyez j'avais un idéal de vie qui
m'avait porté jusque là et ce jour là
dans le bus c'était le moment pour moi
de l'ajuster vous savez comment je m'en
suis aperçu mon corps m'a envoyé des
signaux j'ai ressenti de l'enthousiasmé
avec cette pensée de voyages et de la
déception la frustration avec la pince
et que je pouvais pas c'était mes
indicateurs pour me dire qu'il était
temps d'avoir une discussion avec
moi-même et remettre avons probablement
des questions en croyances mais qu'est
ce qui est probablement remettre en
question mes croyances
donc j'étais en train de dire que j'ai
fait jouer en australie que j'ai eu mes
indicateurs et à ce moment là qu'est ce
que je vais vous dire de super important
c'est qu'on a la chance d'avoir un
merveilleux gps en nous et je crois que
trop de gens n'y prête pas assez
attention aux leurs et se dire je peux
m'en passer
c'est pas la question de savoir si on
peut s'en passer au pas
l'important ici c'est de me rendre
compte que cette idée me rend vivante
c'est comme une flamme qui me donne de
l'énergie et je crois que trop de gens
ne la considère pas sa juste valeur
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
l'effet que ça quand on étouffe trop
cette flamme c'est souvent plus facile à
voir sur les autres îles c'était une
petit à petit ils ont un regard moins
pétillant moins d'énergie plus frustré
la bonne nouvelle c'est que ça signifie
que notre corps fonctionne bien il nous
indique que c'est le moment de faire des
ajustements
alors voilà à quel moment il est
indispensable de remettre en question ce
qu'on croit et d'avoir une discussion
avec soi même quand notre corps nous
parle
c'est simple mais pas toujours facile à
appliquer en tout cas quand on n'a pas
de méthode
d'ailleurs à mon retour d'australie la
décision de suma flammes a été plus
difficile à prendre
je suis donc de retour sur sentier des
études en master comme prévu sauf que
mes journées s'écoulent lentement
alors un jour seul chez moi je réfléchis
je me dis mais pourquoi je fais ce que
je fais et en creusant je réalise que je
suis en train de créer ma vie à partir
de cette question comment je vais gagner
de l'argent plutôt qu'à partir de
celle-ci qu'est ce qui me fait vibrer
vous êtes déjà demandé ce qui est à
l'origine de vos actions quel genre de
vie vous voulez qu'est ce que votre
coeur et votre intuition vous dise moi
mon coeur me disais j'ai envie de voir
les gens heureux
j'ai envie de rendre le monde meilleur
maintenant j'ai pas envie d'attendre
d'avoir 40 ans la maison l'argent de
côté pour le faire ça collait plus trop
avec les études que je faisais et mon
objectif de gravir les échelons dans une
entreprise
alors même si je réalise que j'ai envie
de prendre un autre chemin qui a plus de
sens pour moi c'est une décision
difficile à prendre parce que dans mes
perceptions
ça représente un grand virage maintenant
avec du recul je peux vous dire ce qui
m'a aidé à aller de l'avant
la méthode thomas
comme je savais pas comment m'y prendre
et que ça n'avançait pas je me suis
donné sept jours sept jours ou tous les
matins je me suis demandée ok est-ce que
je lâche les études et je me lance dans
mon projet et c'est mon premier repère
se donner un temps l'idée c'est de
donner une durée suffisamment longue
pour avoir le temps de se préparer et
suffisamment courtes pour devoir rester
concentré alors pour moi sept jours
d'affilée la réponse a été oui et c'est
comme ça qu'a démarré ma nouvelle vie
maintenant si je n'avais pas été aussi
certaines de moi ça aurait été
intéressant que je demande
ok quoi d'autre est possible qu'en
option parce que je sais pas si vous
savez mais une étude de l'ohio state
university a démontré que nos chances de
prendre une meilleure de ses yeux sont
beaucoup beaucoup plus grande quand on
définit au moins trois options parce que
ça nous force à sortir du système
binaire et être créatif
donc c'est mon deuxième repères
envisagée au moins trois options
je suis donc sorti du sentier des études
est prête à me dédiée à ce projet de
rendre meilleur le monde et je suis seul
dans ma chambre je ne sais pas comment
m'y prendre
en plus de ça on me dit julie tu fais
erreur la tma il y 20 c'est utopiste
heureusement j'avais a pris une belle
leçon en préparant mon voyage en
australie
les personnes qui m'avaient lemieux
conseillers étaient celles qui avaient
déjà creusé le sujet alors j'ai appliqué
la même stratégie
quand tu sais pas par où commencer va
voir ceux qui l'ont déjà fait et c'est
mon troisième repères
ce sont nos mentors j'ai donc partis à
la rencontre d'une cinquantaine de
personnes qui selon moi avait
l'intention de l'impact et le mandat
plus ou moins grande échelle et à tous
je leur ai posé la même question comment
rendre le monde meilleur
j'ai récolté des réponses super
enrichissante et puis un jour j'ai posé
cette question
un homme que j'admire beaucoup un des
plus grands auteurs américains du nom de
16 go dean
il m'a répondu tester l'idée sur un
groupe de six
et quand ça marche tu pourras les
répliques et c'était génial comme
conseil
une action que je peux mettre en
pratique tout de suite super et c'est
mon quatrième repères actions même si
c'est un parfait même si on manque
d'assurance
parce qu'à un moment donné on doit vivre
les choses pourra vraiment avancer c'est
le cas de ce thème où j'ai eu mon petit
trou tout à l'heure mais ça n'empêche
que je suis quand même super heureuse de
le faire est de pouvoir vous délivrer ce
message qui est super importante en moi
et qui j'espère vous allez en faire
quelque chose dans ma vie donc j'ai
suivi le conseil de ce 16 go dit je suis
passe à l'action
j'ai testé mon idée sur un groupe de six
on est parti en voyage ensemble pendant
un mois non c'était parfait il y avait
un petit garçon en plus de cinq ans
parfait pour tester comment favoriser un
épanouissement individuel et collectif
j'en ai tiré d apprentissage
une expérience qui valent de l'or à mes
yeux mais tout ça c'est une autre
histoire
le témoignage que je veux faire
aujourd'hui c'est que faire confiance à
cette flamme m'a fait vivre des
expériences qui m'ont nourri l'esprit il
remplit le coeur
un point que les mots ne peuvent pas
décrire je sais que dans la tête de
certaines personnes nous rêves peuvent
paraître démesurée mais on s'en fout
ce qui compte c'est que ça nous donne de
l'énergie
et si ça nous donne de l'énergie c'est
qu'il ya quelque chose à explorer les
questions de savoir si c'est possible ou
impossible ne se pose pas c'est
simplement un moment de creuser le sujet
d'ailleurs souvent on se rend compte
qu'on a dépassé les limites de ce qu'on
croyait possible parce qu'on sait pas
embêtés avec la question alors
j'aimerais que cette tartine de fromage
cet ami sans diplôme et cet auteur
américain n'est pas encouragé que moi à
remettre en question mes croyances
prêter attention à cette flamme et agir
dans son sens j'aimerais maintenant vous
demander de fermer les yeux
imaginez une page blanche
votre vie prend un nouveau départ de la
question de savoir si c'est possible ou
impossible ne se pose pas
[Musique]
vous allez pouvoir prendre une grande
inspiration est expirée santé votre
coeur faites vous confiance
vous êtes libre
qu'est ce qu'il ya de nouveau dans cette
vie qu'est ce que vous faites
[Musique]
quel permission vous vous donnez
j'allais pouvoir ouvrir les yeux mais je
vais vous laisser avec cette question
et si vous faisiez le cadeau de vivre
une vie qui vous correspond encore plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]